our CBS news political contributors
Robby Mook and Terry Sullivan Robby of
course was Hillary Clinton's campaign
manager in her 2016 presidential run
Terry was Marco Rubio's campaign manager
in his presidential bid four years ago
good morning gentlemen good morning a
little over a week ago Joe Biden's
campaign was on life support he was
broke
how do you account for this resurrection
Robbie well I would actually argue this
wasn't a resurrection this was just the
first time that we had a broad swath of
the electorate participating in the
primary you know Iowa and Nevada were
small caucuses New Hampshire is
demographically very unique South
Carolina is actually unique in some ways
it's two-thirds African America this was
the first time we had the entire
electorate engaged and and honestly if
you'd talked to me a few months ago
Biden did as we might have expected him
to do I think just because he lost those
early contests people started to get
nervous I do however think that those
endorsements from Klobuchar and Buddha
judge really did provide him a critical
push because all Democrats care about or
what all that most Democrats care about
is defeating Trump and they were looking
for signals about who's the winner who
can get this done and there were a lot
of those signals coming after South
Carolina
Terry people seem to have mixed mixed
reviews about whether endorsements make
a difference in the past but they
certainly mattered here congressman
Clyburn and the black vote and as Robby
just said the key endorsements from his
former rivals with that in mind as
Bernie Sanders need to get a key
endorsement what does he need to do
because I would think the Sanders base
is also very energized today yeah look
at the end of the day endorsements do
matter but they're almost there more of
a signal of what is happening on the
ground than it is what what they're
actually pretending to show is going
forward you know he at this point in
time you've got a tied race for
delegates it functionally speaking and I
can't imagine that if I would have told
you that a year ago that Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders were tied after Super
Tuesday that there's any Democrat the
country that would have been excited
about that prospect so you know it's
it's all in perspective
at this point Robbie you've seen a
version of this race before back in 2016
you've got Joe Biden on the one hand who
is definitely a Democrat longtime
Democrat classic establishment figure
and then you've got Bernie Sanders who
Biden says is a really Democrat at all
how does this shake out and what does it
say about the divide in the party yeah
well two things first of all I think
it's really important that these
candidates not imputing each other's
character we cannot send a nominee into
this fight with Donald Trump who's had
years to prepare weekend particularly on
their character and so I you know we got
to really hold the candidates to that
but look the other thing I would say is
you know Hillary came out of Super
Tuesday with a lead I you know somewhere
around a hundred delegates we thought
that Sanders was gonna come out of this
with a lead and then Biden was gonna be
able to make that up in these following
contests we're actually in the opposite
what we don't really know because we're
waiting on California right now Biden
has a lead of 80 something delegates but
let's say this is even a tie I would
argue these next state's the tenth and
then definitely the 17th are looking
pretty good for Biden you know I'd feel
good about him in Michigan I think he's
gonna do incredibly well in Mississippi
in Missouri in Washington Washington's
now a primary used to be a caucus so
it's hard to see if this is a tie which
it's not right now but if it becomes one
how Bernie Garner's enough delegates
Terry if you're Mike Bloomberg and you
spent half a billion dollars and you got
maybe a couple of dozen delegates what
do you do today yeah you go to one of
your you know dozen homes on some
tropical island you go to Bermuda like
this is over for him it was it was over
a while ago but now everybody knows it's
over he said he was gonna stay in it we
shall see and Elizabeth Warren quickly
what do you think happens to her now you
know I've been in the tough spot of
managing a campaign for a candidate who
loses their home state it's tough to see
a path forward for her but she served
her purpose for for the establishment of
the Democrat Party but by kneecapping
Bernie Sanders last night and robbing
some some key states and get from birdie
and giving them to Joe Biden like her
home state so she served her purpose for
Joe Biden so now I think it's just you
know the exit for her all right
Robby Mook and Terry Sullivan always
good to see you guys we'll see you next
time
thanks thanks